[Musik]
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video leute max ist an
meiner seite und heute geht es um ein
thema war es sehr viele zuschauer auf
dieser plattform beschäftigt und zwar
man sieht youtuber immer wieder dabei
wie sie vergessen statt zu zahlen sich
die dicksten der autos holen oder auch
mal gerne was ich sagen wir leute es
gibt die verschiedensten situationen man
sich denkt sind youtuber eigentlich
komplett hängen geblieben
dann kann ich jetzt nicht diese und
deswegen testen wir heute ob wir
schlauer sind als ein viertklässler man
muss sozusagen schwerpunkt von diesem
test des biografie das heißt ich wäre
wahrscheinlich gut machen und erst
nacheinander schneiden für euch aber so
dass wir jeweils unsere antworten
nacheinander für jede frage haben und
ich fange an du das machst jetzt okay
wir mit zwölf fragen welches land gehört
nicht zur europäischen union schweden
norwegen dänemark finnland norwegen
leute ich nehm norwegen
naja man wie heißt die hauptstadt von
nord zusammen ist war ein okay das ist
sie das düsseldorfer iss dome jetzt
darüber nachzudenken landeshauptstadt
düsseldorf
ich hab's düsseldorf ja wohl perfekt
genau zu welchem bundesland gehört
dieses wappen geriet das ist hessen
thüringen hessen brandenburg
baden-württemberg ich glaube zu
thüringen aber hessen das hessische
wappen hat auf jeden fall auch mit
ich glaube aber es ist thüringen in
thüringen
was wäre richtig gewesen hessen wäre
richtig gewesen und dieses wappen
wo sehen wir denn welcher viertklässler
kennt button auswendig ich will mich
nichts weiter spencer den leute aber ich
vermute dass ich in dem bundesland zu
dem dieses wappen gehört studiert haben
baden württemberg deswegen ich glaube
ich nehme was sachsen anhalt welches
bundesland ist hier blau markiert das
hier ist bayern das hier ist hessen dann
ist das hier
das ist hessen das weiß ich ganz genau
sachsen ist zu weit drüben wobei
sachsen.de ist thüringen was bedeutet
der maßstab 1 zu 100000 ein zentimeter
auf der karte einen kilometer in
wirklichkeit also 100.000 mal kleiner
also ein zentimeter auf der karte sind
100000 zentimeter in echt 100.000 cm
werden
ein kilometer 100 kilometer in
wirklichkeit ein kilometer wofür steht
das europäische auto kennzeichen e neits
das ist genau mein themengebiete kann
ich irgendwie abbrechen ich bin einer
von diesen menschen die autokennzeichen
auswendig werden ich kenne fast alle
kennzeichen in deutschland auswendig und
deswegen weiß ich dass für spanien steht
für españa estland luxemburg ist ein
nachbarland von deutschland die frage
überspringen wir mal ich sage das geht
mich an der grenze
stimmt ja stimmt das weiß ich doch wie
viele nachbarländer hat deutschland
insgesamt
wie macht also in die niederlande wir
haben frankreich und luxemburg
ich sage immer ganz sicher dass es
18.9 meinte ich möchte neuen egal reden
wenn ich weiter so etwas mal richtig
okay wie heißt der höchste berg
deutschlands dass das zugspitze ein
bisschen zugspitze das weiß ich die
elemente in der nordsee doch in welchem
europäischen land entspringt ein fluss
nord sie da hamburg da polen tschechien
slowakei ist elbe klingt auf jeden fall
einfluss der ausholen kommt weiß man
doch nicht slowakei tschechien und ich
sage tschechen und zu guter letzt leute
wir sind soweit auf gutem kurs wie viele
bundesländer hat deutschland jetzt wird
es richtig peinlich muss jeder für sich
selbst wissen für bundesländer
deutschland für ihn persönlich hat dann
kann man ja oft gewissermaßen für sich
selbst zu entscheiden der eine sagt 3
der andere sagt 20 jawohl der arzt reine
streber leisten dort ist eigentlich
keine ahnung hat sich aber gut
durchgemogelt fünf richtig also leute
wir sehen hier das definitiv jeder
youtuber schlauer sein wird besser von
dieser regel gibt es keine einzige
ausnahme und erst recht keine ausnahme
werden frauen habe mit der man fängt
vielen dank für die teilnahme an dieser
wissenschaftlichen studie leute ich
hoffe ihr seid hier heute findet eine
neue folge was es geht darum wie ein
sketch comedy mäßigen folge darüber
gemacht was menschen heutzutage niemals
sagen würden im internet findet ihr hier
ist die folge mit mir alles sehr gut
gelungen